The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK,
so last time we
continued with our discussion
of design of experiments
and especially looking at
fractional factorial designs,
some of the aliasing
patterns that come up,
and how that interplays
with model construction,
in particular, what terms
of a model you can include,
what you can't
include, as well as
a few ideas on different
kinds of patterns,
things like the central
composite pattern as well as
fractional or full factorial.
What I want to do today is
pick up a little bit more
on response surface
modeling, or RSM.
We've already touched
on some of these,
but there's a couple of
things I've alluded to,
but we haven't really
shown you, things
like how one gets confidence
intervals on the estimates
of coefficients in the model.
Just like when we were
doing some estimation
of statistical
distributions, we would
say we want more than just
an estimate of the mean
or an estimate of the
variance of a process.
We would like to know what range
we might say 90% of the time
with 90% confidence, we think
the true mean or true variance
lies.
Similarly, when we're fitting
models and model coefficients,
we'd like some
notion of what range
we think the true model
coefficients likely lie
based on the data that we have.
So I want to go over
that a little bit.
And then we'll start talking
about using these models
for process optimization,
so combining
a little bit of the
response surface methodology
with design of experiments
both in sequential fashion
and in iterative fashion,
where one might adapt
the model on the fly or based
on the additional experiments
in order to drive the process
or try to seek out and find
an optimum in the process.
So that's the plan.
I've noted here a
reading assignment.
You can read all of chapter 8.
It's actually interesting,
but what I'm mostly focused on
are the first three
sections in May and Spanos,
which talks about
process modeling.
So it's covering a
lot of the material
here on response surface models,
model fitting, a little bit
of regression, and
then also using
these things for optimization.
So a couple of chapters
that have a little bit more
advanced material on
principal component analysis,
which we may come back
to a little bit later.
OK, so that's the plan.
Here's a list of some of the
fundamentals of regression.
When we were talking
about fractional factorial
and factorial design, especially
those formed out of contrast,
that simplified method
using differences
in different
collections of the data,
we found that those
were very useful,
quick ways to be able to
estimate model effects,
to fill those into ANOVA tables
and decide if those effects are
significant, and then
also the relationship
of those for model
coefficient estimation.
I want to talk a
little bit about
the alternative
perspective, which
is regression as a way for
fitting those coefficients.
And we've already
done some of that.
What I'm going to
illustrate here
is our basic assumption
and what falls out
of using minimization of
least square or squared error
estimates in order to
fit the coefficients
or estimate the
coefficients in a model.
And I want to talk a little
bit more about estimation.
We've already
touched on estimation
using the normal equations.
But especially I want to talk
about the variance again,
in these coefficients, things
like the confidence intervals
for fitting of coefficients.
I'm going to do this here mostly
in the context of a simplified
perspective, a one
parameter model.
I just have one
input and one output.
And we'll do the simplest model.
We'll build it up to
a simple linear model,
but all of these ideas
also carry through
for polynomial regression
when I've got multiple inputs.
But I think it's a
little bit easier
to see and discuss in the
context of a simplified--
a simplified model.
And we also talked
last time a bit--
the last couple of
times about lack of fit.
And I have a little
example that carries us
through the development of a
model looking for lack of fit
or seeing lack of fit
and extending the model.
So it's got a small
example embedded in here.
In fact, that
small example might
look familiar to those of
you that saw or took 2853.
It's actually the
same model that I
described in a very condensed
lecture there on regression.
It's also important,
I think, for us to get
a little bit of terminology.
You've probably
run into measures
of moral goodness, an overall
summary measure of R-squared
that is an attempt to
capture how good the model is
in describing what's
going on with your data.
So once one is done, the ANOVA
analysis it's actually quite
easy to calculate both the
goodness of fit R-squared
and the adjusted R-squared as
shown here because they both
depend on--
both of these R-squared
measures and the ANOVA look
at the amount of
variation in your data
and the amount of variation
expressed in your model
and use those to summarize
how good the model is.
So the first measure,
this R-squared,
is basically just
looking and saying
if I were to simply model
my output as the mean, how
much better does a model that
has more than the mean in it
do in explaining the data?
So essentially
what we do is look
at the sum of squared
deviations around the mean.
So this is total summit squared
And then we say OK,
how much sum of squared
deviations based on the
model, so the amount explained
in the model, compared
to the total deviations
around the mean?
What fraction of those
is captured in the model?
So in other words,
if there's really
nothing going on except a
flat dependency, that is,
there is no slope with x.
As I vary x, nothing
changes in the model,
then this simplified
notion of R-squared
is basically saying there
is no dependency on x.
And therefore, I'm
going to explain
with the model
essentially nothing.
Now it's funny because
we are ignoring the fact
that you might also be
fitting the mean value.
But the notion captured in
the R-squared is dependence
on the input, dependence on x.
Now the big gotcha with
this simple measure
is I can always add
model coefficients
and fit more of my
data, or at least I
can do that ignoring
replication in the model.
For Example, we saw with a,
say a two input, one output
model and a full factorial, If
I just have those four corner
points, I can fit up
to a second order model
with the interaction terms.
If I have four data
points, I could
fit the mean, first order,
first order, and interaction
with exactly four coefficients.
And in that case, what
would the R-squared
be if I put my data with
all four coefficients?
1.
I would fit the data perfectly.
Again, this is
without replication.
And I would fit
the data perfectly.
And therefore I'd have
an R-squared of 1.
Now is that really
a perfect model?
Well, kind of, but
what you've done
is you've used all of
the degrees of freedom
in the data to actually fit
or use them to fit the model.
We also don't have any notion of
replication, which isn't really
completely captured.
So one way of
penalizing ourselves
for the use of these
additional model terms
is to essentially have a
different perspective referred
to as the adjusted
R-squared, which essentially
looks at the residual data.
Rather than the deviations
captured by the model,
it's looking at OK,
what deviations are not
captured by the model?
What residual data
would I have, which
also has a side effect of
essentially penalizing us
for the use of additional
model coefficients
because we use up
degrees of freedom
in the model when we
add model coefficients.
So very often people talk
about the adjusted R square
as this fair comparison
between models, especially
between models where I may have
a simplified model with fewer
coefficients and a more
complicated model with more
coefficients.
And essentially what
we do is form it
as the ratio of the mean
square error of the residuals
over the total mean square
variance, if you will,
captured by deviations
around the mean
and then subtract
that all from 1.
And the way I like to think
about it is essentially,
I start with the perfect model.
And then any
residual error, which
could include both replication
error and lack of fit error,
whatever percentage error that
I don't capture in the data--
the sum of squared
deviations divided
by the degrees of freedom,
that's my mean square error
estimate or my estimate
of the true total variance
around the mean.
Whatever fraction of that
that is in the residual,
that's what I'm not modeling.
So essentially what
we're doing is simply
looking at what's not
expressed in the model.
And the model can never
capture pure replication error,
so it's got that variance, but
it might also have lack of it
in it.
So most statistical
packages will report out
both of these numbers.
You can also calculate them.
But it's generally
I like the R-squared
adjusted as a better measure.
In part because it feels
to me a little bit more
conceptual and comprehensive,
in terms of telling me
what's not captured
in the model,
how much pure variation
going on in the data
is not in the model.
However, you have to be really
careful interpreting what
that R-squared is telling you.
It's not necessarily telling you
that your model is good or bad.
You might have a perfect model
given variant noise factors
in the model.
So for example, if
underlying everything,
I've got a true
systematic dependency,
but I also have pure
replication variance,
that's going to limit how good
your R-squared can possibly
be even if your model were
perfect in terms of capturing
the systematic dependency.
I think there was a question
lurking there in Singapore.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so for
R-squared and just R-squared
the closer those values are to
1, the better of the model is?
DUANE BONING: Yes, definitely.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DUANE BONING:
Definitely 1 is better.
But you have to be
a little careful
in interpreting because even--
AUDIENCE: What you just--
no but what, Professor,
you just said
is the R-squared increase both
the error of the model, also
the error of the noise.
So you can't really
differentiate
between these two.
DUANE BONING: That's
right, that's right.
And that's where a lack of
fit analysis-- and we'll
go in and do one of
those as well --is also
still important for being
able to try to differentiate
between those two sources of
imperfection in the model.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Also you mentioned
the second R-squared also being
[INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Right.
AUDIENCE: Your
main concern is fit
and having more
coefficients is cheap,
would you prefer R-squared
or adjusted R-squared?
DUANE BONING: So the
question is what would I
prefer if the number of-- if
fitting additional coefficients
is cheap.
AUDIENCE: And fit
is more important
DUANE BONING: And fit
is more important.
I think I would still
essentially think
of R-squared as somewhat of a
more representative description
of the trade off between adding
coefficients, improving my fit.
But also my R-squared
doesn't get as much batter.
And in fact, if I
start overfitting,
it will tend to degrade
slightly my R-squared.
However, what I think
a better mechanism
for actually making the decision
about whether to include
coefficients or not is
an analysis of variance
and looking at the
significance of those model
coefficients, both the
significance and the magnitude.
So I would tend to do more the
regression analysis together
with the ANOVA.
And the R-squared is a
nice aggregate measure,
but it's not the thing that
drives my decision-making so
much, so I hope that helps.
So we'll see some examples
of some R-squared that
come out of some analysis.
Now we said that regression
is at least as almost--
most commonly used is driven
by minimization of a least--
or minimization of a
squared error measure.
And this is just
trying to illustrate
what I'm talking
about here with where
the residuals, the differences
between my model and my data,
may come from in
the simple 1D case.
We've already talked
a bit about this,
but I'm using a very,
very simple model here,
which has only one term.
It doesn't even have
a constant offset.
It's simply got a linear, direct
linear dependence of the output
on the input.
And I'm saying
that the true model
does have some noise in it,
which is normally distributed.
And I'm fitting that
or estimating that
with some coefficient,
a little b.
And so this is my fit
through my data minimizing
the squared
deviations, or I'd like
to minimize the
squared deviations.
And again, we're saying that any
differences between the model
prediction, essentially the
y hat sub i minus the y sub i
for that data point,
that's a residual.
That's an error.
And it can come from two factors
again, either lack of fit
in the model or because of the
underlying noise in the data.
Now last time, or
maybe even 2 times ago,
we talked about the use
of regression numerically,
if you will or
algebraically, to estimate
this beta with the best
be based on a minimization
of the sum of squared errors.
So we take each one of
those residuals, square it,
and then we sum that
over all of our data.
And it turns out
what we're trying
to do is find the
beta hat, the b that
estimates the beta
hat that minimizes
that sum of squared deviations.
And what's nice
with linear models
is there's an algebraic
way to find actually what b
does that minimization for us.
But I also want
to just remind you
that lurking inside
of that minimization
is an estimate of the total
sum of squared residuals, SSR,
what's lurking back there in
that R and R-squared adjusted.
And then if I divide
that out again
by the degrees of
freedom, mu sub R,
then I've got also my estimate
of variance in the underlying
model assuming no lack of fit.
So we said with least
squares estimation,
I can form the set
of linear equations.
And assuming that the residuals
are all normal or orthogonal
to each other, then the sum
of the product of our residual
and the input should sum to 0.
And when you carry through
the algebra for that,
out plops the formula for
the slope coefficient given
our data, simply the sum
of the product of my x sub
i times y sub i over the sum of
my x sub i squared, it's funky.
And as I said,
here's our estimate
of the underlying variance.
That's our best estimate,
unbiased, best estimate
of the process variance.
And in this case, we're only
fitting one model coefficient.
So I've got my total
number set of data
and then I've just
got n minus 1,
since I've only got
one model coefficient.
Now the interesting
thing that I've
alluded to in a previous
lecture but haven't
shown you is I want more than
just the best estimate of b.
I'd like to have a
confidence interval on b.
Given the spread in the data
and an underlying normal noise
model or noise assumption,
what do I think the range,
say a 95% confidence interval,
might be on my estimation of b?
And we can do that very simply
by taking the formula for b
and simply doing our variance of
b calculation on that formula.
It's just variance math.
And that's what's broken
out here in the y.
If I expand out the b
summation into a some
of those individual terms, I can
then apply my normal variance
math here.
And what I've got for the
variance of that some--
just thinking of each
of these elements
has some constant, then that the
variance of that sum of terms
is the variance of
the constant squared--
or excuse me, the value of
the constant squared times
the variance of each of
those underlying variables.
And when you go and do
that, what you've got
is another formula down
here for the variance
in that coefficient b based
on the data that you've got.
So once I've got
that up here, I've
got my estimate
for the variance.
Now we've got an estimate of
what 1 standard deviation would
be in the variance.
And then you can express that
based on whatever confidence
interval you want.
So I might write that
typically as b plus or minus
1 standard error, 1
standard deviation in b.
1 standard deviation--
I can't remember, what that
correspond to, the typical?
Got about a 90%
confidence interval?
Plus or minus 1
standard deviation?
67%, thank you.
The one I always remember
is two standard errors.
That's about 95% confidence.
So if you wanted to 95%
confidence interval, now
you know how to formulate that.
It might be 1.96
or whatever it is.
So there you have
nicely falling out
of the basic mathematical
formulation for minimizing
the sum of squares
both the best estimate
for your slope and a confidence
interval to the slope.
By the way, if you're based that
on a relatively small number
of data points,
you should probably
use a t distribution rather
than a normal distribution.
So it might change my 1.964
for a 95% confidence interval,
as we're used to.
So this also lets us
now go back and do--
think again about
another perspective
on analysis of variance.
In fact, you guys played
with this a little bit
or saw this in a slightly
different form on the quiz.
There's two ways of thinking
about the significance
whether some slope coefficient
or model coefficient should
be included in the model.
The basic hypothesis
is are we saying
do I have enough evidence to
suggest that that slope term is
non-zero?
If it might be 0 to some
degree of confidence,
then I shouldn't include it.
So one way of doing
it is the ANOVA
with the ratio of
variances in the F test.
The other way is basically
looking at the confidence
interval for beta, say the
95% confidence interval,
and if that intersects 0,
that says that more than 5%
of the time based on just
random variation in the data,
I might have a 0
coefficient there,
in which case I cannot say that
it is significantly different
than 0.
So you can make
that determination
about whether you should include
the model coefficient based
on your confidence interval for
each individual term as well.
So that's just alluding
back to what we already know
but just trying to make
sure you see the connection
or alternative ways of looking
at it either in the ANOVA
table, or if you want to look
at individual coefficient
terms, the confidence
intervals on those individual
coefficients.
OK, let's do an example.
Here's a very
simple set of data.
We've got some input, some
x value, call that "age".
And some y values.
Call that "income".
And if I just plot the data,
let me get the data up here--
actually, what I've
done here is used JUMP.
I don't know how many of
you have played with JUMP,
but I love JUMP because
it's nice and interactive.
It does a lot of
regression analysis,
lets me explore the data
fairly interactively,
I like it a lot better
than Excel for doing
some of these analysis.
I think in an
earlier problem set,
we did give you a pointer
to where you could run that
on Athena and so on.
And what this is doing is
basically looking and doing
my analysis of variance for
a very simple linear model
without a constant term.
So I've just got one
model coefficient, looks
at the sum of squares,
the mean square,
looks at the residual with
the remaining data point
forms and F.
That F ratio is huge.
It's 1,000, and the probability
of observing that large of an F
is minuscule.
So I have great confidence
that in fact there is a slope.
And if I look down here
at my income leverage
residual versus
the age parameter,
I can see this is basically
just y sub i x sub i.
I see a definite trend there.
Now what this nice plot
has done is the solid line
is my best fit, but it
is also plotted for us
with the dashed line the
confidence on the output.
I think it's a 95% confidence
interval on the output as well.
Now I told you how to get an
estimate on the confidence
interval for our b term.
How do we get a confidence
interval on the output term?
Well, what we're
going to need to do
is also do the variance
calculations on our y formula
and see how
uncertainty in our data
also propagates through to
uncertainty in our output.
But before we do
that, we can also
see here in the
JUMP output things
like the parameter estimates
for our age dependence.
So here's our best guess
for the age dependence
is a simple 0.5 estimate.
And it is also showing us
things like the standard error
in these typical ANOVA tables,
which we've ignored in the past
if you've been looking at these.
But that can also be
used them directly,
as we talked about, to give
me a confidence interval,
depending on what level of
error whatever level of alpha
I want to be able to
estimate those things.
And it's also looking
at an individual t ratio
for each of the coefficients.
I've only got one here,
but it's basically
doing a one by one assessment
of each of my model coefficients
to see if it's significant.
And in fact, it's
significant since it's
exactly ends up being the same
probability not really shown
here.
Essentially, the t
test and the F test
are identical in
this simple example.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] think
of some subset of data,
wouldn't it make sense to have
[INAUDIBLE] part of the data
then use some for testing like
the model and seeing if it
actually has a prediction
because if you use that entire
data set then essentially--
DUANE BONING: That's
an interesting point.
So what you're saying
is how about the idea
if you have a fair amount
of data of holding out
some of the data, fitting
the data some portion of it,
and the held back data to
sort of test the model.
And I think, especially when
you do nonlinear models--
and I don't mean
just polynomial,
but I mean some other
nonlinear dependence
--that cross validation is
extremely common and very
useful.
Here, you could do that.
And essentially what
I think that's doing
is allowing you to do a lack
of fit versus noise estimate.
In other words,
what you're doing,
I think conceptually,
there is saying here's
what my model would
have predicted.
Here's my data point.
There's a residual that I'm
going to attribute maybe--
again, it's to a mix of
random noise underlying
but also model lack of fidelity.
I think it's more common to go
ahead and use all of your data
because then you've got
your aggregate measures
and can run all of your tests
with the highest resolution
possible.
But I suspect there's
actually a relationship that's
very close in there.
I think it's a little better
to use all of the data
because the more data you
have, the better your estimates
of underlying
process variance are
so you can better differentiate
lack of fit from noise.
But I haven't thought
about that very much,
especially of the
simple linear cases.
It's an interesting approach.
So I want to come back
to this lack of fit
versus the pure error
because we talked
about often being able to do
multiple runs at the same x
values.
In this data here
that I've shown you,
we actually have a
difficulty in distinguishing
between model lack of fit
and underlying variance.
I had to basically
make an assumption
that my underlying
model was truly linear.
And then I'm basically
assuming, if I
go back even further here--
where did my data go?
--I'm basically assuming a y
sub i is equal to beat sub--
beta x sub i plus
epsilon sub i model.
Why not-- I have really nothing
except ideas of parsimony,
simple models in general
and perhaps prior knowledge
of the physics of the
process to really say this
is the form of the model.
If you look at my data, why
couldn't my model be that?
It may well be.
It might have a very
complicated structure.
That might be true.
The problem is I don't have--
in this random data, I
don't have any replicates
to be able to give me
an independent notion
of underlying repeated
variance noise from model form.
And so that goes
back to what we said
is if we have multiple runs at
the same x values, especially
if we design an experiment
so that we do that,
and we aren't using this
sort of happenstance data,
then we can decompose
the total residual error
into that lack of fit and
pure replicate error and start
to be able to distinguish
between model structure
and and pure replication error.
And so we talked
previously about being
able to form the F
test, the of variance
explained by deviations
from model prediction
in the replicate
data over total error
and then seeing how likely it
would be to observe that ratio
and use the F test in
the ANOVA test for that.
And we'll come back to that
a little bit in an example.
This is a quick one.
I showed you an example here
where the previous example
was a pure linear term without
even a constant offset.
We can also do models
that have both a slope
term and a constant term.
And this is simply formulated
here as a means centered model.
If I were to take my data in
and say when x was added mean,
this term would be 0.
So this is not
really an intercept.
This is saying my a coefficient
is when x is added to mean.
I could similarly formulate
it so that the coefficient
would be when x was 0.
The point being that
the same approach
for estimating both a linear
term and a constant offset term
can apply.
And the same notion of not
only getting estimates but also
getting confidence
intervals based on variances
in those coefficients applies.
So we can also use this to
get confidence intervals,
not only on the slope term but
also on the variance term--
I mean the offset term.
Now we can also, what's nice is,
do the same math now and look
at a variance in our
prediction of the output.
I already alluded to that with
these confidence intervals
on that plot of y versus
x in that one set of data.
And if I basically am saying,
OK, this is my best estimate--
this was my--
this is equal to the a
coefficient --this is my best
estimate of the
underlying linear model
with an offset term, and I just
do my variance math on this,
I've got a variance of
some of these terms.
And if you carry
through that math,
this is just a constant
at each x sub i.
Since x bar is a constant,
x sub i is a constant.
So in the variance
math, when I look
at the variance
of this term, it's
the variance of this times
the variance of this.
This is a constant
term, so I've got
that constant squared out in
front of the variance of my b.
We already calculated
what the variance
of the b a and the variance
of the B term were.
I can plug those in and
get an overall estimate
of the variance of each of
my y sub i terms in my model.
And based on--
once I've got that
for the single standard error,
my single standard deviation,
I can use the t or the normal
to get a confidence interval
on the output.
So it's the same thing we
did on the coefficients.
I can also do it to tell me what
kind of spread, what confidence
do I have in where the true
output should lie when I'm
predicting for
any x value, where
I think the actual true
output y would lie.
Now there's an
interesting aspect
to this, which is if I look
for any given x sub i input
particular x input value,
notice OK, that's right here.
I plug-in for my
particular i of interest.
Notice that the denominator here
was a sum over all of my data.
So that ends up being
just a constant.
It doesn't change.
But depending on what
x I'm looking at,
where I am on the x, the
size of this changes.
So for example, if
I look at my mean,
if I look where my x
sub i is equal to x bar,
that numerator term goes to 0.
And essentially what
I've got in that case
is at the mean of my
data, my estimation
is basically-- my variance
in my output estimate
is basically just related to
the random noise in the data.
But then as I get further
and further from the mean,
my confidence interval
in my output spreads.
So what you will
often see on data--
this was x data and
this is my y --is
near the center of
your data, you've
got the narrowest
confidence intervals.
And as I get further
and further away,
if I were to use the dash for
a 95% confidence on the output,
the further away that I
get in x from my x bar,
the wider my prediction
error becomes.
Even though I'm still
may be interpolating over
the data I've got, my
variance does spread
as I get further and further
away, just an interesting fact.
All right, we're almost ready
to do a polynomial example.
I just want to point out we
talked about this previously.
We can also do not only
a constant term but also
a linear term.
We can do terms that include
this square polynomial,
for example, include
curvature in the x squared.
One important fact
is this is still
linear data in the coefficients.
And what this means is the
least squares approach--
least squares minimization,
still applies.
So you can still
do least squares
minimization to estimate
your beta coefficients.
And essentially what
you do mechanically,
say in something
like Excel, is create
that additional fake column
of data, just taking your x.
You can almost think of this
as equating that with an x2,
think of this as an x1, and
building your data column,
taking each of your x
coefficients, squaring it,
and that becomes a
new x sub 2 input.
And then all you're
doing is just
a linear fit now in these
multiple coefficients.
So it looks exactly
the same like we
did for multiple inputs, even if
we have additional higher order
terms in the x squared.
So let's look at a
simple example here.
Pull these threads together,
look at confidence,
but also look at
it in the case when
I've got some replicate data so
we can get a little experience
with this lack of fit idea.
And so in this case, we've
got importantly here cases
where I've replicated
my x values.
So I've got two runs with 20
grams of some kind of growth
supplement.
And so I've got two different
output values at that point.
And I've got another
point where I've
got three replicates, triply
replicated set of data.
And what I'd like to do
is try to fit a model
and hear what we've
got in the picture is
an inkling or a foreshadowing
of some of the kinds of models
we might consider and some of
the issues we might consider.
If we look--
I think you can see it here
--the basic data here in black,
these are the data points.
So this is just my output.
There's my triply
replicated data.
There Is my x data.
First off, I could try
to fit that with a mean.
That's just the red line.
That's the pure just
mean of my data.
The green line here
is a first order
fit to just a slope
coefficient and the mean,
so two model terms.
And you can see
already that's not
going to be a very good model.
And what we've got is enough
data here with the replicates
to perhaps be able
to detect that using
our machinery of ANOVA, and
then perhaps then build that
into a second order model that
we can already get a sense is
going to be a quadratic
model that fits the data lot
that a lot better.
Now, If I were to just try it--
let's say I didn't already--
first off you should always
plot your actual data
so you have a feel for
what kind of a model
is going to be needed.
So if you were to actually plot
that data, you would already
you probably needed
a quadratic model.
So you might go ahead and
up front, include that term.
But let's say we had
not done that, we'd just
tried to fit it with
a very simple model,
a simple linear model.
And if we go through
and do the ANOVA,
now because we do have
repeated residual,
I can split my overall residual
sum of squared deviations
into a lack of fit term.
That's a sum of
squared deviations
just from my replicated--
or my total deviation from my
model from my replicated data.
And I can formulate then a
ratio of those two things.
And what I've got is
deviations from my model
that are much larger.
So this is a deviation.
It's not a good one.
Actually right, there the
deviation from the model
is quite small.
If I were to look right
here, for example,
this is my deviation
from the model.
I don't have any
replicate data there.
Right here, I've got deviation
from the linear model.
And then I've got
pure replicate error.
And you can start to see that
the deviations from my best
estimate prediction at the
model is much, much larger.
And that's what shows up in
this ratio of the two variances.
If you do that and follow
through with the F,
that's highly unlikely--
that big of a ratio
is highly unlikely to occur by
chance given the noise spread.
So if you actually go in and
do the lack of fit analysis,
it's already setting
up big red flags.
Here's my red flag saying,
look out, look out.
You've got a lot of
evidence of a lack of fit.
What's interesting
in this example is
if I were to just look
at the significance
of the individual model
terms, this pops out in fact
that the mean is
highly significant
but the slope term is not.
So this would say--
if I weren't looking
at lack of fit
and paying attention
to that red flag,
I might be tempted to
say a very wrong thing.
I might be tempted to say
there is a significant estimate
of the mean that's non-zero,
but given the spread in my data,
I cannot conclude that
there is a linear dependence
on my input.
My linear dependence
on x could be 0.
In other words,
with that green line
right here, that's a
small slope that given
the spread in my data is not
justified to actually estimate
as anything other than 0.
Interesting, huh?
So you really need
to look at both.
I'd have to be very
careful because
the extra explanatory
power of the linear term
is very, very minimal here.
So I might think
OK, so I've really
got no dependence at
all, which what I really
got his lack of fit.
That making sense?
So what I might then do is
say, OK, I am paying attention
to that big red flag.
I've got lack of fit.
Maybe I better add a
quadratic term, refit my data.
So now if I look at
the S for my model
with the mean with a term
for the linear coefficient
and one for the quadratic,
now what do I get?
And return to breaking
apart my residual
and now looking and seeing
how much deviation is there
due to lack of fit compared to
underlying replicate variance.
And now that ratio
is very small.
So now I don't have
any longer any evidence
of lack of fit, that's good.
And now I can return
to deciding about
whether individual
terms are significant.
And we don't see the full F
test, it's an incomplete ANOVA.
But what we would
basically find here
is the mean term is
significant, the quadratic term
is significant.
How about the linear term?
It's still not significant.
So in fact, we've got a
a mean and a square term
but no dependence
on the linear term.
You will typically see that.
In fact, these-- if these
terms are truly orthogonal,
if I add the terms, it should
not change my estimates
for the other terms.
That's not quite true if you
throw those missing terms
into noise factors.
But the basic point here is
I've now actually captured
that the dependence on x
with this quadratic term.
So you can do exactly
the same thing.
This is the same
data using Excel.
And you get the
same kind of a table
here with an x term
and x squared term.
And what's interesting
here is you can also
go in and look at estimates
of the coefficients,
the standard error, 95%
confidence intervals.
And I guess actually if you were
to look at that 95% confidence
interval for that x term,
looks like it actually
is likely to be non-zero.
So I did get that right.
So actually you probably
should include that term,
even though the ratio
is a little bit smaller.
It is still significant.
Now I also put this one
up because it's also
got estimates of your R-squared
and adjusted R-squared.
where it's giving
you a nice feel.
R-squared of around 0.9, 0.95,
you start to feel pretty good
about--
pretty good about your model.
So I don't know if you
played around with Excel.
So again, I encourage JUMP, but
if you do need to use Excel,
there is--
under the data analysis
tool if you pull that down,
you will also see the
regression analysis.
And it will let you indicate
what your output problems are
and what your input columns are.
And it does just the least
squares regression, pops out
your ANOVA table for you.
In that case, you
actually have to construct
by hand your wide
square or your x
squared data if you
want to polynomial fit.
And that's what I've
just illustrated here.
You can't simply, unfortunately,
at least in the version
of Excel I have, say I want
to try a polynomial model up
to some order and have
it just know to do that
on the polynomial input data.
You actually have
to create columns
for each of the
model coefficients
that you want to estimate.
Here's the same polynomial
regression using the JUMP
package, again, with
all of the lack of fit
versus pure error, the
x and x squared terms,
t ratios, all of that, but
basically the same analysis
with the second order included.
OK so with that, I'm going
to-- about to move on
to process optimization.
But I'd like to take any
questions on regression,
confidence intervals, confidence
intervals and input, confidence
intervals and outputs.
Is that all?
It's starting to feel--
are you confident in
your understanding
of confidence intervals?
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Definitely
don't know what
do you do if your inputs
that are correlated?
DUANE BONING: OK so the
question was, what do you
do if your inputs
are correlated.
So what is assumed
in all of these fits
is essentially you've
got orthogonality.
If we go back to the
tables we were forming
with full factorial
and so on, we're
assuming that each of your
columns are orthogonal,
which is to say we're assuming
each of your coefficients
in each of your different terms
are uncorrelated or orthogonal.
If they are orthogonal, and you
do a least squares regression--
or if they are not orthogonal,
there they are correlated,
what happens?
Well, what happens is you've
got to model coefficients
both trying to explain some
amount of the same data.
And they fight
against each other.
And it's almost
random how the effect
that-- that true underlying
effect gets apportioned between
say a beta 1 and a beta to term.
In fact very, very tiny
little perturbations,
and you can get a different
mix of beta 1 and beta 2.
And it turns out
you might still be
OK in terms of
predicting an output
because at least your model
has both of them in there.
But it really screws up
your ability to decide
is that model term
significant or not.
What you need to do
is transform your data
to get it into an
orthogonal form
to get rid of the correlation
to basically create do
model coefficients and
new explanatory values
to fake x values that don't
have the correlation in them.
And the classic
tool for doing that
is principal component
analysis or some transformation
of the data to a different basis
than your original x1, x2, x3
coefficients.
We might talk a little bit
about multivariable things.
I think we did a little bit with
multivariable statistical and T
charts and so on,
but essentially
a principal components or some
other kind of transformation
is needed on the
data in order to then
have individual
coefficients that
are not duplicating each other.
If you look, I think it's
chapter section 8 point--
maybe 8.4.
The next one after what I
assigned as a reading, that
talks about principal
component analysis
and how you do that
and process modeling.
So you can read that section.
It's actually very
good, very interesting.
Other questions, progression?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If there
is a big difference
between R-squared and
adjusted R-squared, what
is that telling us?
In this case, it's essentially
[INAUDIBLE] 0.9 and 0.8,
or 0.7 [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Yes,
so the question
is what if you have
big differences
between R-squared and
adjusted R-squared.
I think it's
essentially telling you
that the influence of
additional model coefficients
is really important, both--
this very qualitative.
But essentially,
it's telling you
there's more than going on
than just the mean response.
So you're seeing a little
bit of a mix of both--
the penalty of adding
more model coefficients,
but it's also
telling you there's
likely additional structure
that you needed in order
to use that.
But that's pretty qualitative.
I think basically it's
signaling that there's
more than just mean--
mean deviations going on.
It sounded like there
was a microphone
question in Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Question on slide 50.
You mentioned we should
only see the mean which
also focused on the lack
of fit and the pure error.
So why do you say that
we only see the mean,
we may say it's a good model.
Can you explain that again?
DUANE BONING:
Yeah, actually what
I was saying in this
example is that if I only
looked at the mean, I might be
hesitant to include any model
terms beyond the mean.
So I might not actually think
it's a good model at all.
So that part of your question,
I'm not sure I quite understood
or quite agreed with.
But I do--
I guess maybe I'm
just repeating myself,
I think it is really critical
to look for lack of fit
because you need
both perspectives.
You need to look not only at
model coefficients in terms
and whether they should
be included in the model,
but you also have to be
alert am I missing terms.
That's what the lack of
fit enables you to do.
This is basically saying
the terms that are there,
are they significant?
So in some, sense this one
is basically just leading
you to throw away coefficients
and throw away model terms.
And this number two, the
lack of fit, is telling you,
hey wait a second, there's
stuff going on in the model
that you're not
explaining that's
different than random
noise, so maybe you
should add model terms.
And so you need
both perspectives.
OK so I think we're ready to
move on and look a little bit
at process optimization.
I want to touch on the most
natural use of these sorts
of models, which is we define
an experimental design,
we go gather the data,
we build a model,
and then we start
playing with the model.
I think of that is
offline use of the model,
using it to try to
identify an optimal point.
But it's not purely
offline because I
want to make the point that if
you're predicting an optimum,
you probably want to go back and
run some confirming experiments
and use those back with
your physical process
to check your model and maybe
even iterate and improve
your model.
So that's one natural approach.
And the other is--
that should be online use.
So another clever approach
is actually build simplified
models in a little part of
the space, use that to tell me
what direction to move in
exploring my overall process
space, and then dynamically
build and improve my model.
In the case when my real goal
is getting to an optimum,
not having the perfect model
covering all of my space
but rather get to
an optimum point.
So I want to touch on
both of these ideas, ways
of using these sort of
simplified response surface
models.
And part of the point
here is one important use
of these models really is trying
to find an optimal process
output or find the inputs that
give me an optimal process
output.
And that optimal
process output may
have multiple
characteristics about it
that are important for us.
One is I want to be
close to a target value.
But the other is we may
also want small sensitivity,
small deviations in my output.
And if we go back to
our variation equation,
that may mean I want small
deviations around noise factors
that I'm not controlling.
And I may also want
relatively small sensitivity
even to some of my
input parameters
because I'm going to
fix them in my process.
And I'm not dynamically or in
a feedback loop changing them.
So in some cases, I want
this to also be small.
So we'll talk a
little bit about ways
to mix in these and
other objectives.
For right now, I'm
going to mostly focus
on say trying to meet some
set of target mean values.
But I can make the
point you can generalize
what I'm going to be talking
about here by thinking
of some objective function,
or some cost function,
or some goodness function that
actually mixes in together
multiple objectives.
So some of the objectives,
you might have a cost function
that penalizes for
deviations from the target
or maybe sum of
squared deviations
if I have multiple
outputs from the target.
It may also penalize me
for larger x's because--
larger input because
there's more cost
associated with using more
gas if I have a higher gas
flow in some process.
And then I can also
include other things
like terms that penalize for
sensitivity, these delta y's,
sensitivity to the output.
And I can keep throwing
additional things in.
So if I've got in general some
complicated objective function,
if I can formulate
that and actually model
either empirically or
analytically that cost
function as a
function of my input
or as a function utilizing the
models that I already have,
I can then formulate an
optimization function
or an optimization
problem where I
might be trying to
minimize that cost
or minimize that objective.
Or maybe I'm trying
to maximize it
because I think of it as really
a goodness function rather
than a penalty function.
But overall, I've got some
complicated form for J
as a function of my factors.
Or my factors might
be my actual input,
but they may also be noise
factors, other factors that I
haven't explicitly modeled.
And we'll talk about robustness
next week, or not next week,
on Thursday.
But right now, I
just want to talk
about adjusting or searching
for good input factors
to minimize or maximize some
cost function with constraints.
So in general, you can think
about different approaches
for this.
If I've got a full
expression for y
as some function of x and
maybe J is some function of y,
I have overall got some
overall function for my cost
as a function of my inputs.
Then I can go in
and try to minimize,
really dj dx and find--
with some assumptions
of monotonicity,
I can find an overall minimum
or at least a local minimum
or maximum to that function.
So that's if I've got
a full expression.
And we'll explore
that a little bit.
Another approach is more
of an incremental approach.
Rather than having
the full expression
and leaping right
to the optimum point
based on a local minimum
or local maximum,
I may have to search for it.
I may have to iteratively
explore the space.
And we'll talk a
little bit about these
with hill climbing or steepest
ascent and descent kinds
of problems.
And I've already
mentioned a little bit
of this online versus offline.
So here's the simplest
picture for one
of these optimization problems.
I've got my input x, and
I've got my output y.
And what I'm looking for is
a maximum for my output y.
And maybe here simply
my cost function
is simply J or J is equal
to y, something like that.
So I'm not differentiating
here too much between y and J.
I'm just simply saying
what I'm looking
for is the overall
maximum for this output.
And one knows from basic
geometry, basic algebra
that the maximum will occur--
unless I hit some
constraints or some boundary
cases --will occur
when I've got zero
curvature in that function.
So how do I find it?
Well, one approach is, again,
this analytic approach.
If I have a full
expression, I can simply
recognize that
that minimum occurs
where there is zero curvature,
solve for the y such
that that curvature is 0, and
I directly get to the answer.
But in order to do that, I
need a full analytic model.
To do that, I needed
perhaps relatively small
or good accurate increments
and x or assumptions
on the model form.
And especially if I have
relatively sparse data points,
if I had say just
these data points,
it's quite easy to miss
the true optimum because
of noise or imperfections
in my model fit.
So it can actually be a little
bit tricky with small amounts
of data to find that if I
fit an overall analytic model
to a very small
number of data points.
An alternative is a little bit
of an iterative or a search
process where we might actually
add data or explore or model,
either explore experiments or
explore a model in a smaller
space in each case and sort of
seek to find the optimum point.
And here are a simple
conceptual idea
here is in some
regions of my space,
I may have very good
model fits less so
than with much less
error than trying
to fit this overall quadratic to
a small number of data points.
I may have relatively
good model fit
in smaller regions of the space.
Remember that confidence
interval on the output?
I said as we get further
and further away from say
the central moments of our
data, my confidence interval
on my output prediction
gets wider and wider.
If I shrink my space,
I get better estimates
of my model in a local space.
And so one approach
here is to say,
I'm going to look
in a local space
get a good estimate
of what the slope is.
Maybe it's a reduced order
model that's only linear.
So I'm not even trying to
fit additional curvature.
And then use that
to say my output y
is increasing in this
direction with x increasing.
And use that to project
forward a small amount
and suggest a new
x value to try.
So it's projecting and
additional steps to explore.
If I then do that and build
an additional linear model--
whoa --build an additional
linear model here,
it might suggest
another small step.
And as my linear model starts to
have a slope turn that shrinks,
that's telling me I'm
getting something closer
to an optimum point or at
least a local optimum point.
And at that point that's
signaling me that if I really
want improved accuracy
at that point in space,
to really zero in on the
maximum, I can do two things.
One is still constrained
my search space.
But also in this region,
it's quite likely that my--
it's quite likely--
I don't want this.
I don't know what that was.
Oh, wow, something
funky happened.
In this space, it's just like
with that curvature model
that I showed you
earlier, the linear term
is probably no longer
very significant.
I really need the
quadratic term.
So I might fit locally
a quadratic model just
near the optimum which allows
me in a restricted space
to get an accurate model
that really lets me zero in
on the optimum point.
So out here, a linear
model might be good
enough up in here.
I may need a beta
0 plus a beta 2 x
squared term, maybe still
also with a linear term
here as well.
But I can basically
build dynamically
the model getting an accurate
model near the optimum point.
Now, I showed you this
in 1D, the point 1D,
but you can also do
this with two inputs,
where I've got a 3D model if
this is an x1, this is an x2,
and this is a y.
But you can essentially
think the same thing.
If I start out here in this
space, locally it's linear.
I can use that to
suggest the next step
to take using a simplified
linear model in this region.
And then as I hill climb up,
as I get close to the optimum,
then again now near
the optimum, I need--
as my x1 and x2, I may
need a quadratic model
in those two coefficients.
But I can extend the same
idea to hill climbing
not only in one input, but
two inputs, three inputs,
multiple inputs in order
to get to an optimum point.
So essentially what
we're doing here
is, again, linear
gradient modeling,
it is useful often to include
still an interaction term.
But essentially we're doing
exactly that same thing.
And if my model
itself is linear,
an interesting thing happened.
Where is my overall optimum?
If I'm trying to
get to maximized y,
where's my maximum
y going to occur?
It will always occur on a
boundary when I hit a limit
of my input and x's.
So an important thing that
I haven't talked much about
is also the notion of
additional constraints.
We may be driving to an interior
point like in this model,
but it's also
possible that we may
be driving to either a corner
point or some other boundary
point because of a constraint
on my allowable ranges
for my x inputs.
There is another
piece of terminology
that's sometimes used for
these kinds of searches,
either steepest descent
or steepest descent,
whether you're climbing or
looking for a local minima.
And the basic point is when
I've got that simplified
linear model perhaps with
the linear interaction term
as well, you can think about
the local gradient with respect
to x1 or the local gradient
with respect to x2.
And now when you make your
step, what you often want to do
is make the step in the overall
steepest descent direction,
changing both your x1 and x2
parameter at the same time.
So this is simply
showing when I move
and hill climb, I may change
x1 and x2 proportionally
depending on the relative slope
in those two coefficients.
And it's relatively
easy once I've
got that model to
decide what direction is
the overall steepest descent.
Another point here is
that with quadratic terms,
you can have complicated
functions where your minima may
occur in the interior of
the space or your maxima
in the interior of the space.
But you can also have
hyperbolic or inverse polynomial
kinds of relationships
where, again, you
may have local minima or maxima
with respect to one variable
depending on what you're
doing with the other variable.
Or you may also have places
where you end up with a maxima
again at your constraint points.
So in your search, you've
got to account for both.
So I can summarize
what we've done here
with a combined procedure
for design of experiments
and optimization in either
the iterative fashion
or at the end, I'll allude to
evolutionary or incremental
kind of version.
So this is a summary of the last
two or three lectures boiled
down into a reminder-- a
summary of the basic process
or procedure for doing
DOE and optimization.
We said originally
our goal here is
to build a model, to do
a design of experiments.
I do want to
emphasize that depends
on some knowledge of the
process, a little bit
of knowledge either
experience based
or in the physics
of the process.
Because you need that
in order to do things
decide what the important
inputs are likely to be.
Now there are things you can
do with the DOE to confirm that
or to expand your knowledge,
like factor screening
experiments.
We talked about
fractional factorial
with large numbers of
coefficients where you're just
trying to decide is there
a main effect associated
with that factor.
But up front, defining the
inputs is very important.
We also need to define
limits on the inputs.
What space do we want
to explore and build
a model over in our
design of experiments?
So overall, we're going to
need to first build our--
decide on a DOE.
We'd go and run our experiments.
And then we're going to
construct our response service
model.
And if we're using it
for the optimization,
I also want to make
the point that you
need to think early on about
what your overall optimization
or penalty function is
because that may strongly
influence your DOE and maybe
even your factor selection.
So for example, if you
believe that you're really
going to need an optimization
that folds in things like noise
in addition to just
trying to get to a target,
that can have a profound effect
on the DOE that you explore.
And we'll talk about
that on Thursday,
where you might do
additional small experiments
at each point in
the DOE in order
to build a sensitivity
model of that delta y
as a function of some
additional noise factors.
So depending on
what it is you're
trying to achieve with your
model, that can of course,
I guess it's obvious,
that can affect
the structure of your model
and the design of experiments
that you want to do.
So we've already talked
about a lot of this.
Again in summary,
your DOE includes
decisions about what
likely terms you think
might be in there based on
your knowledge of the physics.
Is it going to be mostly linear?
Might there be quadratic terms?
That can influence
again the selection
of the high-low center points.
Do you need center points,
do you need three levels
for all factors, and so on.
And you also need to think about
things like the noise factors.
We talked about these
nuisance factors, if you will,
or additional noise factors.
So that you might randomize
or block against those.
If they're not going to be
explicitly in the model,
you don't want them
aliasing with or confounding
with the terms you actually had.
The response service modeling
is actually a pretty easy piece,
especially if you use
things like the regression
and the ANOVA approach.
Again, you can use
contrast, if you've
got a highly structured
design and experiment
for very rapid estimation
of those terms.
But overall, the
emphasis here is
you're trying to determine if
there's significant variation
in your data, are individual
terms significant,
are you missing terms.
So that lack of fit is
extremely important.
And there's often a very
interesting interplay
with the regression modeling.
In fact, an approach we
haven't talked about much,
but it's essentially
inherent in what
we've been talking about
here is also referred to as--
I think it's-- not
piece-wise, step-wise,
step-wise regression.
And some of the
interactive tools like JUMP
actually explicitly
support this,
where one factor at a
time, you look and say,
I would like to
add a term or drop
a term based on cut off decision
points, on significance,
and so on.
So you can build up an
appropriate regression model
by dropping or adding
terms as needed.
And we talked about this at a
fairly high order or high level
about the optimization
procedure and again, just
ideas of defining
your penalty function
and then searching
for your optimization
either piece-wise
or analytically.
I'll come back to
this in just a second.
But I do want to
emphasize that once you've
come to some expected
optimum point,
you really should check
that and confirm that often
because you're building
your estimate of your model
based on relatively
limited data,
especially in the
factorial models
perhaps with only one interior
point or center point based
on mostly extreme old data.
And especially if you've
driven your optimum
to some interior point
using say the analytic model
of the response service
model rather than iteratively
or incrementally, you're
making a lot of big assumptions
about the shape of the model
right near your optimum,
like it's convex right
at that optimum point.
So you really ought to go in
and do a confirming experiment
right at or right
near your optimum
in order to really
test the model
and consider model error
right at that point.
And that might actually drive
you to improving the model
or exploring slightly different
space right near that optimum.
Now the one last
thing I just want
to allude to is an
alternative approach
here is often starting with
some data point in a small space
and building your model
iteratively or adaptively.
And next week, at
the end of next week,
we'll have a guest
lecturer, Dan fry,
who has actually studied
one factor at a time
incremental exploration
and model building
for the purpose of
optimization a great deal.
So he's going to lead us
through an alternative approach
of actually doing
full factorial models
but trying to find the optimum
by not defining up front
the whole DOE and
running the whole thing,
but rather just walking
around your multifactor space
in order to try to
find the optimum point.
And that has some relationship
to another approach that
is also in May and Spanos in
chapter 8.5 which I've just
mentioned to you but not
expect that you actually
have to know a lot about, which
is evolutionary optimization.
Which would say build a
local model use that again
and a hill climbing fashion
to suggest where you
want to go for your next point.
Maybe in fact you simply
pick one of those corners.
And then you build a
do model around that.
And it might suggest
you move your process
to another corner, in which
case you build another model
and so on, so that you
can walk or evolutionarily
arrive at an optimum
point in your process,
building local
models along the way.
OK so next time, the
one additional topic
I want to mention in this space
of optimization and process
optimization and DOE is
this notion of robustness.
I'll allude to actually
building models
that include the
variance in them
and not just the overall output.
So we'll come back to that
on Thursday and enjoy.
In the meantime, I think
you've got the problem that
is due on Thursday.
And it's going to let
you explore a little bit
more some of these DOE and
response service model kinds
of things.
So we'll see you on Thursday.